Hey there, intrepid
iOS developers.
And welcome to this quick
tip episode of Route 85.
So check this out.
What you're looking at
here is a little app
that I wrote that lets me
configure this secret robot
army I've been building.
It's a side project.
Don't tell my manager.
Now, you can see
by the storyboard
here that it goes
several layers deep
as I select my
robot's personality,
mode of transportation,
and weaponry.
And then we get to
the end, and, well,
I've got to back up a bunch
of times in my navigation
controller to get
back to my main menu.
It's kind of awkward.
So there are a few ways
we could address this.
One way is by using code.
When I finally select my
weapon in the last screen,
I could add in a
little code like this,
and everything would work.
I jump back to the main menu.
But not always.
In a simple example
like this, sure.
I know exactly what order my
view controllers will be in.
But that won't
always be the case.
What do I do in a
situation like this,
where I want to jump to
this controller here?
Well, sometimes,
it'll be at index 1,
and, other times,
it'll be at index 2.
So now my code would have
to search through the stack
until I can find the one I
want and then pop to that one.
It's an awful lot of
code just to jump back
to a view controller.
Isn't it?
Yeah.
Not to mention that
now, by using code,
I've introduced
some inconsistency
in our navigation logic, right?
Some of our navigation
follows segues that
are built into our storyboard.
But some of it now
relies purely on code
that has no corresponding
entry in Interface Builder.
If another developer were
working on our project,
they'd have to
start looking around
in, like, all of our files to
see what additional navigation
logic we've added instead
of being able to rely
on one consistent system.
And we're engineers.
We like consistency.
So the other option is
to keep using segues.
Now, you might initially think
of doing something like this,
adding a segue that goes from
our final view controller
back to our first one.
But that would be a bad thing.
See, by doing so,
I wouldn't actually
be jumping back to the
first view controller.
My iOS app would create
a new main menu view
controller to put on top
of my navigation stack.
And I would end up
with a giant pile
of view controllers like this.
Yeah, that's not
really what I want.
So a better solution here is
to create an unwind segue.
This is a segue you
define in your storyboard.
And it basically does
what it sounds like.
It tells your
navigation controller
to unwind through all
of its view controllers
until it gets back to the
target view controller
that you have specified.
Now, creating an unwind
segue is similar to creating
a normal segue, except that
instead of Control-Dragging
to the target view
controller, you
Control-Drag to your view
controller's exit object.
It's this little icon
here in your storyboard
that you've probably
been ignoring.
For example, let's say I want to
make this Cancel button go back
to my main menu.
To do so, I'll just drag
from my Cancel button
to this little Exit icon here
in my outline, and, let's
try that again.
Oh.
Oh yeah.
That's right.
OK, so this is the thing that
confused me with unwind segues.
To use one, you first have to go
to your target view controller,
the one you're
going to unwind to,
and add a blank
ID action method.
In this example,
I'll create a method
called unwind to main menu in
my main menu view controller.
And you'll notice
that I'm passing
in a UI storyboard
segue as an argument.
Now you have to do this,
or else Interface Builder
won't know that this
is a destination
for your unwind segues.
It also comes in handy
later, as you'll soon see.
So once I have that
in my view controller,
I can go back to
Interface Builder,
Control-Drag from my
button to this Exit icon
here in my view controller,
select the method I just
created-- here it
is-- and, voila,
I've created an unwind segue.
Now, when I click this
Cancel button in my app,
it will jump back to the view
controller that contains this
unwind to main menu method.
And I don't have to worry
about where in the hierarchy
it's located, which is nice.
And now I can use it just
like any other segue.
So let's revisit our
original problem.
To go back to the main menu from
my last view controller here,
I can Control-Drag from
that view controller
to my exit point to
create the segue.
Then I'll give it an
identifier, like I
would with any other segue.
And then I can call perform
segue with identifier
to get back to the main menu.
Let's see it all in action.
OK, here it goes.
Going, going, oh, much better.
It gets me the logic I wanted.
And I'm insulated from
major storyboard changes.
And I get to keep
all my navigation
logic nice and consistent.
Oh, and, as an added bonus,
if I need this first view
controller to grab any
information from that last one,
I have a chance to do that in
my unwind to main menu method.
It's kind of the opposite
of a traditional prepare
for segue method.
In this case, I can query the
previous view controller--
this last one here--
before it's disappeared
from the navigation stack, which
can be very useful sometimes.
So this quick tip
was shared with me
by our very own Gus Class.
He writes a number of our
sample mobile applications,
both on iOS and
Android, that you can
find in our GitHub repository.
He also dj'd at Burning
Man with a laser light
show that he built
himself, which
is way cooler than anything
I've ever done in my entire life
ever.
So you win, Gus.
But what about you?
Do have a quick tip?
Do you wear clothing?
Well, then have I
got a deal for you?
Send me a quick tip, and if
we publish it on the air,
I will send you a T-shirt.
What a bargain!
And as for the rest of
you who, I don't know,
I guess don't wear
clothes, I'll still
see you soon on "Route 85."